des transports innovants et récompenser
un maillage efficace qui continue
d'évoluer pour s'adapter aux besoins des
usagers la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines anticipe les
modes de circulation 2 demain tout en
répondant aux demandes
aujourd'hui c'est tout de suite c'est
maintenant bagdad
faciliter les déplacements est essentiel
pour renforcer la qualité de vie et
l'attractivité économique et à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça fonctionne
plutôt bien puisque la communauté
d'agglomération a vu son territoire et
son travail récompensé le 3 juillet lors
des trophées de la mobilité mais un
réseau d'avenir est un réseau qui évolue
sans cesse pour s'arrêter aux besoins
des usagers
une nouvelle gare ou queyrac une mise en
service au début de cette année au nord
du faisceau ferrée au niveau du secteur
de la radio
cette nouvelle gare accueille neuf
lignes interurbaines qui me
principalement aux pour l'urbain autour
de l'agglomération dont près des
secteurs comme cergy-pontoise comme par
ligne comme bologne pour ce qui concerne
le réseau bus nous avons une nouvelle
ligne qui a été mise en place entre
saint quentin et la porte d'orléans donc
une ligne de carre très confortable avec
trois nouveaux cars qui ont été intégrés
dans cette relique elle aligne donc que
les un pied les regards de saint-quentin
l'ordre dans les rangs
cette ligne aujourd'hui est structuré en
heure de pointe au quart d'heure en
heure que ça c'est des nouveautés à
l'aide à l'heure cette ligne a également
été renforcée avec un nouvel arrêt qui
est mis en place depuis le 18 août
sur le secteur des faits un complément
également important concernant
l'accessibilité des personnes à mobilité
réduite puisque trois nouvelles lignes
sont à présent accessible donc à ces
personnes et donc d'une forte la ligue
417 et la ville 418
parallèlement nous avons fait un travail
très important aussi
depuis le début de l'année sur tout ce
qui concerne donc les transports en
commun se croient donc notamment l'
amorce du transport non ses propres
entre la gare de la verrière et la gare
de trappes
donc nous avons amorcé une concertation
qui se finira le 12 septembre pour le
doublement du pont schoder donc cette
première séquence améliorera d'une
manière très importante les engorgements
que l'on constate sur ce secteur-là
elle s'intègre d'une manière plus
générale sur une inflexion plus de
balles et de travaux qui sont menés par
l'attenté des cotations en lien avec les
communes et un ensemble de partenaires
pour réhabiliter l'ensemble du secteur
de la gare de la verrière pour l'ami
dans le sens de la verrière la défense
une plus grande amplitude horaire le
matin d'un quart d'heure et le soir
d'une demi heure donc avec de nouveaux
trains qui sont à disposition par les
cff nous avons aussi une menace très
sensible qui se mettra en place le
week-end avec des trains demi-heure et
m'ont plu à l'heure donc une
amélioration notable pour les saint
quentinois sur l'année à partir de la
fin d'année un réseau qui bouge donc
mais pour aller encore plus loin l'agglo
s'est également investi dans une
opération d'importance et les de
nombreux volontaires pour essayer
pendant deux semaines de se passer de la
voiture donc on appelle ça le défi de
semaine sans voiture on en a retenu huit
on a huit volontaires qui sont prêts à
essayer soit le but soit le train soit
le vélo soit les lois séance électrique
et nous avons comme ça des saint
quentinois qui vont essayer de découvrir
leur territoire autrement pendant deux
semaines on va servir d'exemple on a
déjà plusieurs collectivités qui nous
ont contactés en demandant si on pouvait
il pouvait avoir le retour de cette
opération
peut-être de nouveaux adeptes des
circulations douces quant à vous si vous
souhaitez en savoir plus sachez que
soutient ce mois ci la désormais
traditionnelle semaine de la mobilité à
saïda mobilité comme initiatique il y à
déjà de maintenant nombreuses années qui
est à l'échelle européenne et qui incite
les gens à essayer d'autres modes de
transport que la voiture particulière
elle se tient toujours à 1070 du 15
au 20 septembre avec en temps forts une
journée grand public le 20 septembre
tourner autour du vélo on attend tout
les tous les saint quentinois qu'il
désire devant le vélodrome ils pourront
faire réparer leur vélo gratuitement
jusque ils n'auront qu'à payer les
pièces il pourrait aussi essayer des
vélos assez délirant possibilité
d'essayer d'évaluation ces prix de
france est niée sur la mobilité
alternative
et qui dit mobilité dite aussi co
voiturage une alternative que la casse
qui encourage elle soutient notamment la
solution de covoiturage domicile travail
mis en place par la société
wise of cette solution innovante a en
effet connu un succès important auprès
des salariés du technocentre renault
d'éthique et de snecma à 50 ans divise
hop c'est une solution de covoiturage
spécialisé sur les trajets domicile
travail
donc en fait on apporte tous les outils
aux salariés pour pouvoir comme mature
et très facilement sur leur trajet
domicile travail donc sélectionner les
meilleurs covoitureurs avec le moins de
détours pouvoir s'organiser même quand
on finit pas tous les jours à la même
heure avec des alertes en temps réel et
un module de partage des frais qui
permet en fait de faire ses comptes tout
simplement vous covoiturer pendant
quinze jours un mois avec différents
covoitureurs et l'application à vous
dire combien chacun se doit
on s'est aperçu que le covoiturage est
très développée sur plutôt les longues
distances donc un covoiturage
occasionnel du week end mais il manquait
un outil spécifique pour répondre aux
attentes des salariés sur les trajets
domicile travail
donc en fait on fonctionne avec avec les
entreprises et à sainte-thérèse de la
chance parce qu'on a quatre clients
entreprises qui sont renault snecma
haïti et le crédit agricole est donc en
fait dans ces entreprises on a mis en
place le service
ce qui est intéressant sur saint quentin
c'est que vous avez plus de trois quart
des inscrits qui ont trouvé au moins un
covoitureur sur leur trajet et alors
donc il ya un vrai réseau de transports
alternatifs qui est créé à saint quentin
grâce au covoiturage et que donc les
salariés peuvent utiliser tous les jours
une solution qui a valu à weather un
trophée de la mobilité en juin comme
c'est une belle reconnaissance pour nous
et pour les entreprises du territoire
ainsi que la castille qui était notre
partenaire et donc ça va nous permettre
maintenant d'étendre le service partout
en ile de france où il ya des besoins
sur des zones en périphérie et ou le
covoiturage peut avoir un réel impact
pour les salariés
voilà vous êtes toujours dans bien vivre
et dans cette deuxième partie nous
concluons notre série consacrée à la
présentation de vos élus aujourd'hui
encore trois vice présidents de la
communauté d'agglomération françois de
lier bertrand puyo et alain hajjaj
bonjour françois de ligne et vice
président chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la vie étudiante domaine
que je connais et que je vis en tant que
maire de guyancourt et conseiller
général de monter d'une brutale vous le
savez l'université est née sur notre
territoire l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines est née sur ce
territoire de la volonté des élus les
élus qui vire à bout de bras emporté ce
développement est on connaît aujourd'hui
un véritable rayonnement une
reconnaissance nationale et
internationale que nous devons continuer
évidemment à défendre alors cette
délégation pour moi comprend trois
enjeux importants le premier c'est de
continuer à développer l'offre de
formation pour pour les jeunes et
également évidemment le la recherche et
notamment comprendre un exemple
l'observateur du climat le deuxième
enjeu c'est également le lien avec le
développement économique
l'université doit permettre avec son
développement de l'emploi et notamment
l'emploi des jeunes
et puis le troisième enjeu c'est celui
de la vie étudiante
avoir une université vous savez à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est pas un
territoire avec l'université c'était
interdit un territoire qui est
véritablement un territoire
universitaire et donc avoir des
étudiants on en a plus de la moitié sur
les 20000 et bien c'est prendre en
compte leurs besoins en matière de
logement en matière de transport je
pense aussi à leur intégration dans la
cité et puis pour terminer je dirai
également que en nous tournant vers
l'avenir que nous sommes dans une
opération d'intérêt national
saint quentin en yvelines fait partie de
l'opération du plateau de saclay et pour
demain sur cette opération d'aménagement
à cheval sur le département des yvelines
et de l'essonne
nous devons continuer à promouvoir notre
université a coûté à magny les hameaux
je suis une mère donc de la commune
depuis septembre 2012 je suis né ici à
manier en 76 alors à l'agglomération
donc je suis vice président en charge de
la politique publique de réseaux les
réseaux c'est tout ce qui concerne le
gaz l'électricité
les footballeurs est également
l'assainissement l'eau potable avec les
services de l'agglomération
nous travaillons à une mise en place
d'une harmonisation une homogénéisation
de l'ensemble de ses réseaux
je pense par exemple à l'eau potable ou
on a plusieurs tarifs on appartient sur
50 ans 12 pour les sept communes à
différents syndicats et l'objectif par
exemple dans ce domaine est de pouvoir
aux mobiliser l'ensemble des prix et que
les habitants de la collectivité puisse
s'y retrouver dans d'autres chantiers il
ya par exemple ce qui concerne
l'éclairage l'éclairage public qui est
une nuisance par rapport par rapport à
notre environnement et avec l'objectif
de pouvoir justement avoir des
des évolutions diminution d'éclairage en
soirée mais tout en maintenant un
éclairage qui est un besoin par rapport
à la sécurité des habitations
et puis dans les domaines de
l'électricité et du gaz c'est la
possibilité donc de nous regrouper avec
d'autres collectivités dans de l'achat
public justement du gazelec je suis
maire depuis mars 2010 réélu c'est en
2014 cette année
par ailleurs je suis vice-président de
l'agglomération chargé du développement
durable de l'environnement et de la
coopération décentralisée nouvelle
présidence une nouvelle gouvernance
probablement nouvelle orientation donc
il va nous falloir travailler ensemble
pour définir un peu les axes de cette
nouvelle gouvernance bon mais j'ai
effectivement proposé au président que
nous poursuivions le travail que nous
avions engagés c'est à dire en matière
de développement durable la
consolidation de notre plan de
développement durable avec tout à parti
le volet énergétique le plan climat est
important tout le travail que nous avons
engagée sur la biodiversité la trame
verte et bleue
sur cette agglomération et puis un gros
travail qui a été fait que peut être pas
toujours suffisamment mis en valeur mais
le travail des entreprises locales pour
leur participation développement de ce
territoire
donc le réseau d'économie sociale et
solidaire le réseau des entreprises
responsables sociétale et puis le plan
climat énergie nous avons monté sur la
question de l'environnement bien écouter
d un patrimoine important il nous faut
l'entretenir le développer et enfin sur
la coopération décentralisée pour une
coopération renforcée en direction du
mali
et puis le soutien aux initiatives
locales qu'elles soient de la part des
communes ou des associations
et voilà donc pour vos élus quant à
notre dossier sur les transports vous
pouvez le retrouver dans le petit
quentin du mois de septembre ainsi que
pleins d'articles intéressants comme par
exemple celui qui est consacré aux
journées du patrimoine et qui vous
demain en plus un programme complet des
activités à faire ça quand on m'a
demandé alors moi je vous souhaite une
bonne rentrée
je vous dis pour mois prochain
il